you mentioned Edinboro I don't know I
know it has some in fascinating history
I've never been there I've always wanted
to go to the comedy festival in
Edinburgh and and I've sworn I'm gonna
go there someday but I don't know much
about the the city itself it has an
incredible history right it does it's
the most haunted city in the world
really well no because ghosts don't
exist you did this yeah okay but yeah
the history of Edinburgh is absolutely
screwed so basically when the Black
Plague was wiping out most of Europe
Adam Ramage to survive a bit by just
being utterly utterly ruthless and how
they dealt with it because they couldn't
come up with any medicine they just
decided to build a new Edinburgh on top
of the old Edinburgh and if you were ill
they just sort of brick to you into your
house what yeah yeah genuinely the
doctor would come around and check you
one day and they'll be back tomorrow to
let you know where your diagnosis is and
then you open up the door the next day
and they're just breaking you and being
like sorry it's real perhaps there's
mass keep in mind that was that was a
house call back in the 1300s that's how
they took care of things yeah they just
braked you in there you and your family
just to get the kids and everything
Edinburgh is built on a city of people
that were entombed alive because they
were sick yeah yeah so basically all
yeah yeah yeah
and there's also like mass graves every
couple of thousand feet but it's yes it
was it was not a good time and you know
I'm done if I could say on the air but
you know the time shit-faced yes if
someone's had a lot to drink we say
they're shit-faced yeah comes from
Scotland so basically obviously there's
no sanitation back in the good old days
so if you need it when you were doing
your business during the day you'd do
your business and just a bucket so all
the pee and all the number two's would
go into that sort bit and there's how I
grew up by the way oh yeah yeah it's
rough on the outskirts of bars always
just a little bit too late late to catch
up so they there was a time of night
where they just agreed to throw out the
window at about 7:00 p.m. and everyone
would throw out there and it would run
down at the same time just so it wasn't
happening all day and you would when you
showed through the window you show in
the words Gardea loo which is a sorry Lu
which is it's discouraged way of saying
gardening law which is French for watch
out for the water which is a very polite
way of saying here's a bucket a peek
at your face yeah that's people's two
other things as well other things as
well but some people would get too drunk
during the day there after they finished
work and they'd walk outside and they'd
forget what time it was because Watchers
didn't exist and someone above them
would show something in French and
they'd look up and that's how you were
so drunk that you were shit-faced yeah
that was so lovely some of you tried to
join up second yeah that was this is the
saddest history lesson I incredibly you
should have this is the kind of history
that's so dark and sad was the woman
that died twice what in Scotland right
so back in the back in the days there
was a time when you used to do a tour
guide there I I will be I don't think I
want you to be but I know what this
pretty flower is I don't know what
that's all about
come over here I'll show you the toilet
that never stops
if you come to Ed and I'll show you the
toilets tubs so basically there was a
time in Scotland where you were allowed
to hang women for cheating on their
husbands no matter how awful the husband
was part of the tasty so there's woman
she cheated on her husband and they hung
her to death and everyone checked the
body and she was dead and then they
threw in the back of Atari okay card to
go take her away throw in the ditch
whatever they throw dead bodies and she
just woke up in the back of the thing
and the guy when the horses will be like
God like terrified that this zombie is
now alive right and but the debt because
they'd signed the death certificate she
was legally considered dead and
therefore divorced there was like you
were now kids live an entirely separate
life and she lived to be 65 years old
called remarried to a guy that never
cheated on her that's a happy story I
thought what you were gonna say is that
they came back to and they were like oh
hang her again that's what I thought oh
that's where I thought it was going on
seemed like nice people with off yeah oh
no the taught the torturing the went on
in Edinburgh to the back of the days
we'd say yeah because I think that's
where my university was a lot Madison
with him hey you have University of
Edinburgh which is considered one of the
greatest medical universities
of all time yeah and the reason I
started it was because obviously when
after the Dark Ages which was were in
Christianity essentially banned all sort
of medicine whatnot admiral was one of
the first universities to start doing
again but you can't really test on a lot
of bodies because that hurts people well
you can do is you can test on dead
bodies but the fresh of the body the
better is there was these two guys
called Birkin hair who started going
grave-robbing to begin with trying it
like they'd literally wait until the
funeral was done and wait till the
family left and run and get the body and
take it to people could at least
experiment and find out about yeah yeah
check it what's on the insides and then
they realized there was there was more
money in fresher corpses than that and
they became mass murderers so they they
would kill people just to make fresh
bodies yes and then Edward shows
initiative
yeah and also who who likes digging yeah
that's a good kind of thinking okay wait
a minute why wait right well yeah it did
help us I'm not justifying I do have one
do you have one Pleasant fact about
Edinburgh I'm just curious everything so
far has been horrible about this it is
the birthplace of golf is it not well
Scotland is I don't know if it was
admirably particular can't you just
claim that so you have one semi pleasure
oh no I like I love the dark history
yeah I bet you're gonna say like oh no
we back then we used human bones to play
golf yeah yeah and there you take the IO
and then you find put it back into the
eye socket and if you did it quick
enough they could see again yeah that's
the science that we learned from all the
bodies stupidest thing I've ever heard
did you play a lot of golf growing up I
did I usually put it on the road or like
my granddad signed me up he just want me
to play with him to play with a until is
about 13 or 14 and then girls start
kissing me and I was never played golf
since
I'm not saying the people that play golf
you know don't have a sex life I'm just
suggesting it you're suggesting there's
a better use of your time yeah yeah oh
yeah because I'd love to get it's a fun
game i did enjoy playing it but like
when you're 13 years old and everyone
and then cuz like you've done instead
you were 13 when you started kissing
girls okay 50 but whatever
15 still depresses me how old were you I
was in my late 30s
oh we're telling Joe
[Laughter]